we need to change things fundamentally
while people will still even give us an
opportunity to do so like it will even
give us the trust and confidence to
think that we can change things for the
better because like the ultimate enemy
here is just despair is just utter
hopelessness and despair whatever Joe
Biden does if he gets elected it has to
be big it has to be bold you know
there's no doubt that the Affordable
Care Act was a big leap forward but it
was as the president said the other day
President Obama it was never meant to be
the final step it was a step forward
there is an opportunity to do big
structural things like the one you've
suggested universal basic income I think
the things that have that have seemed
sort of utopic and radical in the past
now seem like pragmatic answers to a
large number of Americans
[Music]
I am thrilled to welcome to yank speaks
or vice-versa this is the yank speaks
x-files crossover it's like a superhero
team-up Marvel DC yeah exactly now it's
great to be with you and Royce and what
an irresistible pairing you know yes
it's like half of a CNN studio has come
to life exactly and everybody misses
those so how have you been yeah I've
been good in the scheme of things just
working hard trying to do as much
positive stuff as possible get money out
to people we're now at six and a half
million dollars in direct economic aid
to people in micro grants of between 250
to $1,000 I just launched this data
dividend project this week I don't know
if you saw that we're trying to get
people paid for their data so that's
really exciting and positive yeah so
we're staying busy just trying to do
good things obviously trying to help Joe
whenever they ask me for help or so
we're hosting an event for him online
with tammy duckworth next week that's
great that's great well he must be
feeling good right now
sitting on top if anyone had told you
that going into July that Joe Biden
would be leading the race by 12 to 14
points you would have told them they
were nuts and it speaks to the Caprice
of American politics because no one
could have foreseen in early in the
early part of this year all of the
intervening events that have really
exposed Trump in a very very dramatic
way you know there's all this talk about
masks he's really been unmasked by these
crises and it's it's turned this race on
its head
you know the bunker strategy of Joe
Biden which obviously is not like a real
strategy I mean it just
like happened happen I yeah but I
experienced it on the trail where I
remember when he won Massachusetts and
he'd literally spent zero days in
Massachusetts and zero dollars and zero
staff and seeing that it's like wow like
Joe like Joe can win without setting
foot anywhere in the state and we're I
think we're seeing that again now where
Joe's built-up name recognition and
familiarity is so high with so many
Americans that it's not like you need to
see him necessarily every day on your TV
screen or at a local rally in order to
feel like you know him and that you're
willing to support him yeah you know I I
don't know I think in some ways he's a
very familiar figure in other ways he's
not I think that the way people know him
though is the most significant way right
now which is they know him to be a
decent human being they know him to be
an empathetic human being they note and
they know him to be a caring human being
and those are qualities that they are
sorely lacking or that they see is
sorely lacking in Trump in the midst of
these crises and so it's really x Daan's
advantages but that whole strategy of
not going and not spending any money man
if you had just done that imagine you
could have been the nominee if you just
spent nothing in Glassell even if I just
had popper advice and guidance instead
of these other jokers that I had here's
the plan
Andrew bask in total anonymity and then
you will be catapulted ya to the front
of the pack it'll be the greatest
political jujitsu anyone has ever seen
yeah yeah I think the strategy requires
total familiarity before you start
basking in in anonymity but listen your
your team your team and you did an
amazing job when because youyou
literally started in total anonymity and
you made yourself a factor in
presidential race and that's a hard
thing to do you know 25 people or
whatever the number was ran very you
know and a handful of people really
elevated themselves in that race you are
one of those people nobody would have
bet on your surviving as long as you did
in that race so all kidding aside hats
off to you and your team because you you
ran an unconventional campaign and you
captured the imagination of a lot of
people so there's there's a lot to be
said for that well thank you David you
and I had a chance to spend time
together on that trail you know I was
with you at the University of Chicago
which was a tremendous event we also
bonded over our families however how are
you and your family faring during this
time we did bond over that and it was
something I deeply appreciate we both
have special needs kids mine my my
daughter has grown now she just turned
39 years old and the hardest thing about
this siege this kovat 19 siege has been
that she lives in a wonderful place near
us in Chicago and they've and and they
are taking wonderful care to make sure
that she and her friends are not being
exposed to the virus but the but the
requirement is that she either comes
home and stays with us for the duration
of the virus or she stays where she
lives in in the place where she lives
and we can't physically see her because
they don't want anybody coming in or out
who might infect I mean that makes sense
it was an either/or situation and she's
you know look they're doing a great job
she is there's lots going on there she
loves being with her friends and so we
couldn't remove her from that she would
have gone crazy after a week of being
away from them but but it's hard and
she's getting frustrated she has you
know she has a job she can't go to
and and and she is she'd like to come
home and visit and and you know so it's
that's been that's been very painful to
be separated but you know in the main
look what I found Andrew and you
probably as well if you were lucky going
into this you're probably handling it
pretty well you know I I was lucky and I
mean I'm lucky enough to be lucky in
that I have places to be out of the out
of the crosshairs of the virus I my
wonderful wife and I have been married
for 40-plus years and we still can stand
being under the same roof with each
other and enjoy that and and I've spent
time my son came down to our place with
his fiancee we spent a month with them
at the beginning of this Wow so you must
gotten to know her much much better yeah
exactly yeah so I mean this is all these
were all great benefits but you know I'm
cognizant every day that it hasn't been
as easy for a lot a lot of people in
this country and what it's done is
exposed the fault lines in our economy
that you talk to so eloquently
throughout your campaign people are you
know the the there are people who live
in this country who are one catastrophe
away from ruin and the catastrophe came
and you see a lot of small business
people losing their businesses you see
many people losing their jobs and and
obviously a lot of people suffering with
this virus one of the things that is
bugging me this week is this
unbelievable scenario where the
President of the United States who's in
charge of running the government that we
count on to respond to the virus is also
leading the resistance to the advice
that his own government is giving and so
at a time when Arizona
which is a place where I spend a lot of
time Arizona is now headed into the red
zone in terms of this virus he arrives
and the other day spends time in an
arena or I guess it was a megachurch
with 3000 young people crammed together
no masks and it is exactly the scenario
that the CDC has warned about and so you
see the president the United States
actually aiding and abetting this virus
and you know it's a it is something I
thought I'd never see but you know so I
feel for everybody who is suffering with
the virus who have lost loved ones and
who have lost their livelihoods as a
result of this it's a terribly difficult
time
[Applause]
it's a catastrophic time there was a
commentator called it the Omni crisis
which I've since adopted but you you
have this pandemic that then is giving
rise to Depression era levels of
unemployment and then now we have police
brutality civil unrest layered on top of
it and no like how do you dig out of
this when your president is literally
just as you say going against public
health experts going against common
sense we have to start digging out of
this and I think all the time about the
people who've lost their livelihoods I
just saw a story where 95 percent of New
York real estate in Manhattan is still
unused
and so you have these hot dog vendors
and coffee vendors who like push their
trucks out to the offices waiting for
customers and then no customers ever
come you know I mean how long can that
go on for those families to me we should
be dumping money into the economy and
people's households as quickly as
possible just say look the economy is on
fire people's lives are getting
destroyed like we we just need to try
and put the fire out and to me it's a
mystery where if 72 percent of Americans
are for cash relief like why isn't
Congress debating that every day I feel
like that's bipartisan the polls I saw
said a majority of Republicans and
independents are for cash relief as well
as Democrats so that that to me is like
is something I also spend a lot of time
on right now I was trying to help
candidates push that bill through
Congress it's being considered in the
house right now and Senate it's got I
believe it's up to a couple dozen
co-sponsors and in some cases humanity
forward is supporting opponents of
members of Congress who are not signed
on to the cash relief bill because to me
right now if you're not into cash really
then you're just missing what's
happening well and I think it speaks to
the wisdom of your longer-term proposal
for universal basic income to put that
floor beneath people and also to also to
recognize that people have worth in our
society who are not rewarded for that
now including parents who who are home
and taking care of a special needs child
for as one example but you know one of
the things that has been interesting and
exasperating is listening to the
president and all when he talks about
the economy all he talks about is the
stock market well half the Americans
don't have stocks don't have equities
and that's not though that's not where
the crisis is you know and I understand
that it's open for corporate America to
have capital and and I'm not you know
but the real crisis is in the ability of
people data data survive in a time when
our economy is still in many ways shut
down it's certainly not at full throttle
so your proposal takes on new resonance
because as I said before it's not just
this crisis but there are families all
over this country who are who are a
tragedy away from another financial
crisis and that will be true even when
the economy is restored yeah the economy
being restored I've been trying to
figure out what the recovery looks like
and the estimates I've seen say that 42
percent of the jobs are gone for good
which makes sense to me I you know you I
would estimate half and so if economists
come in with 42 I'd say ok 40 to 50
percent of these jobs are gone forever
that alone puts you at 16 to 18 million
jobs gone and we can look around us that
many of these states that are reopening
they're not coming back
100% full-bore I mean you can see in the
restaurants and
and I haven't been to an airport but I'm
pretty sure that airports fairly
sparsely used right now manifestly uh
and so and and you just mentioned I mean
you're we're seeing surges and cases in
Arizona and Texas and Florida that are
going to end up having you know like
obviously a huge dampener on anyone
feeling secure and going out and doing
things that would help drive the economy
to me at this point the main variable is
the vaccine and when when you and I were
talking about this election in November
Trump's down by an historic amount for
an incumbent at this point I mean you
know much more about past elections than
I do
certainly I'm not sure it's unusual for
the incumbent to be down 12 points you
know for four months out mm-hmm yeah no
I think this is this is a this is a very
pronounced deficit for an incumbent and
and frankly given how inelastic our
electorate has been it's a big margin
for any any race at this point that said
four months ago we didn't foresee any of
this we don't know what the next four
months are gonna hold we know that trump
is a guy who is completely untethered by
norms and will do anything to win and
he's got the levers of government
I expect on the vaccine he will under
any circumstance he will announce a
vaccine whether that vaccine
materializes there not after November
third he will announce a vaccine and he
will he will I think he will overrule
Republicans in the Senate and he will
extend unemployment insurance and and
frankly they he should do that but you
know he has some tools available to him
to try and change this thing up and and
then we have the issue of voting and how
that's going to go and the opportunities
for voter voter suppression and
so you know my my advice to the Biden
camp is to enjoy these numbers but don't
inhale because there there's there's a
lot to go here and you've got a you know
in baseball they say see the ball into
the glove make sure that you catch it
they've got to see this right to the
very end and and it you know their this
is not Trump is not going to go out
meekly he will you know now I I think
Andrew that his that his problem is that
his reaction is to double down on what
he knows I mean he hasn't shown the
ability I mean what he what is killing
him right now is his own behavior the
way he's handled this virus and the the
initial denial and now another round of
denial telling people that this thing is
going away at the very time that and
standing in the very state where no it's
actually peeking again it makes him look
obtuse and and you know completely
focused on his own storyline rather than
reality his handling on these his
handling of race you know now kneeling
was his tactic back in 2016 no he was
the guy who made Colin Kaepernick who
put a big target on Colin Kaepernick now
he says he's going to use US Marshals to
protect statues around the country and
he just announced I guess that he's
gonna have a big event at Mount Rushmore
on on the 3rd of July so what you see is
this is his new kneeling is gonna be
protecting statues and you know it's
code for other things but but he doesn't
have the ability you know the American
people it seems to me are showing a
great character in their reaction to all
of this and and he is not and they know
it and what's driving his numbers down
is just how miserably he's handled the
virus how how miserably he's handled
this race issue you know it when the
economy was going well and everything
to be going well people who were on the
bubble would say you know I hate the way
Trump behaves but everything's going
well and you know he's strong and he
knows how to get things done and so on
well now he doesn't look very strong and
the cost of incompetence and divisive
miss and narcissism is becoming very
clear to people and it's going to be
hard for him to come back from that you
know not that he can't but it is he's in
a very deep hole and he's got the shovel
in his hand I couldn't agree more
72% of Americans and one survey I saw
said this is the darkest time in
American history in their lifetimes I
mean that that's not the kind of thing
that makes you want to sign up for four
more years of the incumbent and yeah you
look at this and he's got an ax he's dug
himself in historic hole I agree that
his go-to playbook is is looking worse
and worse like it you know just trying
to lean into some cultural flashpoint
and say look I'm here defending the
statues I'm here I'm gonna go to Mount
Rushmore the Kong flu or like you know
whatever distraction he's going to try
and use I feel like it's not working and
he's getting increasingly desperate
because he can sense that none of it is
working but he doesn't really have
another playbook to go to and to me
Democrats are so traumatized by 2016
where anytime you say to them hey Joe's
winning they're like oh no but we
thought Hillary was winning and look
what happened so don't don't believe the
polls no Trump is going to pull a repeat
so I look at the four and a half months
ahead and I agree with you that that's
like the major variables that four
months ago we couldn't have predicted
this so what happens in the next four
months
is there a vaccine that changes people's
mindset or a sense about the future the
debates would be another possibility
I suppose though I'm skeptical that that
would actually be a key well let me
interrupt you let me interrupt you on
that let me interrupt you on the debates
cuz I think it's a really interesting
thing you know the Trump strategy right
now is Biden is an addled you know weak
doddering old man and he's not really in
control in down in in Tulsa he said you
know he's going to surrender everything
to the radical left to the mob and so on
but the other half of that equation is
he's arguing that Biden doesn't have the
strength to bring the economy back and
now but the whole premise is Biden
doesn't have the mental acuity to be
President which is kind of remarkable
coming from a president who advised the
country to ingest Lysol as a strategy
for dealing with kovat 19 I mean he's
not exactly a poster child for mental
acuity but beyond that he's really
lowering the bar for Biden in these
debates I mean he is painting such a
dark picture of Biden's capacities that
when Biden shows up and you were on at
the bait stage eleven times yeah he's
going to clear that bar I feel pretty
confident and and you know back in your
you're too young to to have at least who
maybe have focused on this but 1980
Ronald Reagan was running against Jimmy
Carter the country you know it was
double-digit inflation and unemployment
and and you know the country actually
says malaya stagflation yeah and he was
going and the country decided they were
gonna fire Jimmy Carter but they weren't
sure about Ronald Reagan they felt he
was too too extreme to right-wing too
dogmatic and they had won debate and
Ronald Reagan showed up and he was
genial and he was warm and he was
reassuring and the bottom dropped out on
Carter
after that debate you know it's possible
that Biden can actually seal this simply
by clearing the very low bar that Trump
has set for him and that's the you know
that's the downside of the Trump
strategy he's painting Biden in a way
that I think Biden can easily SWAT aside
and and and so he may have been he may
be setting his own trap here Trump
that's a great point
it's true that if you present Joe as
completely infirm then he shows up and
is a completely normal stable competent
fired up and that doesn't even need to
be fired up is what you're suggesting as
long as he clears the bar now so yeah I
I agree with your estimation that it's
unlikely that the debates are going to
somehow be some launching pad for Trump
particularly if he's saying that no dud
like Jose is caricature of himself and
so I look up and I try and imagine what
the paths to victory for Trump are and
to me a lot of it comes down to voter
suppression are people able to vote in
November and have their votes counted
we're seeing already now with all the
mail and votes at the state level well
first we saw massive lines and
difficulties in Georgia but then we're
also seeing a multi-day counting period
for mail and votes in in many states and
so the questions in my mind are around
November 3rd it happens and then are we
going to know like yeah whether that
vote ends up being something that people
have trust in confidence in like that to
me is a major variable that it's tough
to tough to predict or forecast I think
that would be one way you can imagine
this somehow going very very very badly
for the country as a whole if you wind
up yeah this contested
affection that drags on for days and
days well listen Andrew there are only
two outcomes in Donald Trump's
estimation either he wins or the
election was stolen he doesn't allow for
any third option and you know that he's
already setting up the storyline mail-in
votes lead to fraud I think that's a
little bit of a trap for himself too
because he's making mail-in voting
socially unacceptable for his own voters
and that could end up hurting him but
you can see what he's doing and and yes
I think if you look at the elections we
just had these primaries in Kentucky in
New York we're not going to know the
outcome for a week or more because of
mail-in voting that is going that is
very likely going to happen in states
around the country in 2000 and and 20 in
the fall and I there could not be a
worse time for that if you had a person
who had some regard for our institutions
and his constitutional place in Donald
Trump it would be one thing but he he
cannot accept defeat and so he will
instead try to tear down the process and
create a sense of of jaundice about the
result and he'll have help in that I
mean this is part of the Russian project
and other malign forces in the world who
want to create you know doubts in the
minds of Americans about their own
democracy so it is a date you're
absolutely right to point that out and
it's it is a great concern and we all
ought to be eyes open about this and as
much as possible resist the temptation
to be or not the temptation but resist
the impulse to be manipulated by our
worst fears here I mean the fact is
there is no history of massive voter
fraud in our country nor is there a
history of massive voter fraud or any
major voter fraud attributed to mail-in
voting and we should not allow that
storyline to to compound yeah so that to
me is the biggest unknown most
legitimate concern because I look at it
and I don't think the economy is going
to come roaring back between now and
November
I think the vaccine is a major variable
that you're right that he may move
heaven and earth to have something that
he can at least talk about but it's not
like anyone's going to be actually
vaccinated at any scale prior to
election day I so to me the landscape is
very Pro Joe and I mean he's up now like
I don't see that changing barring
something calamitous on the Joe side
really you know like it's his Trump is
digging himself a deeper and darker hole
I think a lot of it is just that
Democrats are very very scarred where
they just cannot bring themselves to
breathe easy which I understand because
you have to run through the tape and see
the ball in the glove as you're saying
like we have to work work work I mean
it's one reason why I'm co-hosting
events for Joe and and doing everything
I can to help him win but to me
objectively Joe is winning Trump is
losing and there is no reason to think
that something's going to turn that
around in the near future unless the
process ends up being such a mess that
we can't have confidence in the results
so that's something I'm also trying to
help with on the side there are some
people I know who are working on clearly
the mail and modere voter provisions in
states around the country I mean to the
extent that those aren't in place in
some states you have to ask yourself
like what the heck are you doing
especially given the current background
[Music]
so one thing that happens when you run
for president is you become like a bit
of a mattress connoisseur because you
sleep on so many different mattresses
you're like ooh this place is a good
mattress and what if you want a good
mattress at home then helix sleep has
you covered
go to helix sleep and get yourself the
top-rated mattress according to people
who know and love mattresses can you
imagine having that as a job evaluating
mattresses that seems like a sweet sweet
gig I can say with confidence and Roo
that none of the hotels in Iowa New
Hampshire that we stayed in had helix
mattresses they were not very
comfortable maybe we should have brought
a mattress with us wherever we went and
then that would have been freaking
awesome just throw like a jumbo mattress
on the bus and then live and cool like
it Emperor when I came off the bus I'd
be like but helix is offering up to $200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at helix sleep
comm slash yelling that's a tli x sleep
comm slash yelling from the $200 off a
top notch mattress they deliver it to
you it's in a box it's beautiful we
could have fit the Box on a bus easily
FYI
but regardless helix sleep comm slashing
200 bucks off make it happen
[Music]
[Applause]
you know one thing I wanted to talk to
you about me you have like this storied
political history helping many people
win the one that one that we all I
believe know you for most prominently is
obviously Barack Obama you helped get
him into the White House
I guess twice if you want to look at it
that way you helped him get him into the
White House and stay in the White House
and and you've been working with him for
years and years and I read this op-ed
that you wrote that I believe in the
Washington Post where you've been an
ally to not just Barack but black
politicians for decades yeah and you
you've considered your whole career
really yeah your entire career and so
you consider yourself someone who's
helped make history on that side and yet
now you're thinking that the work that
you've done wasn't enough that there
were disparities that were bigger and
deeper even than what you were seeing
and I feel like many Americans I've also
been awakened to some of these harsh
racial inequities by the killing of
George Floyd and black lives matter yeah
listen I think this is a historic moment
you know I've lived through a lot of
these moments in the television age and
you know I remember what the civil
rights movement did in terms of raising
consciousness they the the the brutal
assault on marchers at its Selma led to
the Voting Rights Act but this is
different this this because for the
first time in my lifetime and I think
for the first time in the life of our
country there is a broad public
discussion about institutional racism
systemic racism that that really flows
back to the beginnings of our country
and what I wrote was that I am I am
ashamed that I haven't spent more time
thinking about that that
systemic racism and you know I have yes
I've worked for a lot of candidates of
color from the beginning of my career as
a political strategist and I helped you
know break down these barriers but I
haven't had a lot of conversations with
my black friends about what their
day-to-day lives are like what are the
things that they fit what were their
encounters with police like what we're
there you know what were the barriers
that they faced at work what are the
slights that they've endured you know
they're there you know
kareem abdul-jabbar said you know when
you expose it to the light when you
expose America to the light you know you
see racism everywhere that is true and
we have just accepted this as a kind of
well that's you know those things are
sort of a part of life and I think that
a lot of people are now taking another
look and saying it's not just how police
treat citizens help police treat people
of color it's it's it is pervasive in
the workplace it is pervasive in social
settings we just never have afforded to
our our black brothers and sisters their
full rights we have not it has not
happened in 400 years and I think people
are that's why I think Trump is meeting
such resistance here there is even
people who Andrew who are not really
that motivated by this issue understand
that the last thing we need is more
divisive mnestheus more appeals to to
separation to to to discrimination and
bias and so on I mean Trump has
weaponized race as an issue at a time
when people want everyone to put those
weapons down and focus on the real issue
yeah
yeah how can we start to heal and
address some of these century-old
inequities certainly for me part of it
is universal basic income and starting
to balance out the economy in ways that
work for people of every background but
particularly for people of color and
women and folks who are completely
marginalized by our current economy at
which it's going to be more and more of
us and I obviously made the case that
it's going to be a lot of us due to
technological change but it was already
happening to black and brown people and
women and underrepresented minorities
and and a lot of the people that we're
talking about you just need to try and
make things work better for more people
and the most direct straightforward way
we could do it would just be to start
putting money into people's hands
directly so that your kids have a better
chance to learn you have a better chance
to think I just met yesterday with four
women they were all women in the Bronx
who received a thousand dollars from
humanity forward we gave a thousand
dollars to a thousand people in the
Bronx that were identified as struggling
economically and one of them said that
she had I don't know if she was
exaggerating but she said she had five
dollars in the bank and and then she got
a thousand so then it was like a
thousand and five and she said that it
helped her think more clearly and that
really was like a punch in the gut for
me because I think that there are so
many people in our country that have had
that I can relate to that now certainly
this doesn't solve all of the racial
inequities that we're talking about but
at least it gets us like you know like a
little bit down that path
my greatest fear David is that things
just aren't working for more and more
Americans and you and I for better for
worse are like part of these
institutions and frameworks and like you
know establishments and like I can see
for many many Americans like they're
just losing confidence that any of our
stuff is working and that that there's
like a presumption to the work that you
and I do which is like look if we can
get some people into power and passive
policies and like actually try and right
this ship we can improve things but I
feel like fewer and fewer people are
listening and that there's like less and
less trust in faith that one we know
we're talking about or or can like
understand what other people are going
through and to that there's actually
going to be something meaningful that
changes for them you know like that
there's like and I've called it like the
era of institutional decline or era of
institutional distrust and at this point
it's rational to distrust which is
freakin terrible like I think that's
where it's gotten to for many many
people and and for these issues of
racism it's it's so deeply embedded
where like if you're a black person
looking up and saying like Cornel West
this also hit me like a gut punch when
Cornel West said like look we've tried
black faces in high places and nothing
has changed for us so like what what do
you expect us to do at this point and
you hear that and you're like holy crap
like we need to change things
fundamentally while people will still
even give us an opportunity to do so
like it will even give us the trust and
confidence to think that we can change
things for the better because like the
ultimate enemy here is just despair is
just utter hopelessness and despair and
I can see despair growing and rising
throughout the country I mean right now
we have like you know this amna crisis
like mental health crisis that pre-pre
existed before the pandemic and now like
the mental health crisis on steroids and
so thinking that we're going to somehow
reason people to a point where it's like
no if we come together we can do x and y
and z people are just losing hope yeah
listen I think that we are at a critical
juncture and there there's no doubt
you're right about the crisis of
confidence about all our institutions
and you know it comes at a time when
change is
coming more rapidly than ever and
because of social media there is an
immediacy to all of this that I think
creates a that adds to the anxiety and
so and so we have government this is a
mismatch that's always bothered me or
that's been bothering me lately you've
got government that is designed in a
democracy to move slowly when public
opinion is divided and we've seen the
impact of that over the last many years
and then you have changed coming more
rapidly than ever because of technology
and you know that is a very very
difficult mismatch and it you know what
what I think more than anything is that
whatever Joe Biden does if he gets
elected it has to be big it has to be
bold there has to be a willingness to
really rethink fundamental institutional
relationships and he's got to do things
that if he gets elected he will have to
do things that really substantively make
a difference you you know there's no
doubt that the Affordable Care Act was a
big leap forward but it was as the
president said the other day President
Obama it was never meant to be the final
step it was a step forward and it needs
to be accelerated I think there's an
opportunity to do that now I think
there's a public receptivity to do it
especially after the crisis has laid
bare so many of the problems with our
health system I think that the you know
there is an opportunity to do big
structural things like the one you've
suggested universal basic income but you
know I look at these for example these
inner-city communities I live on the
southside of Chicago and I've seen
communities hollowed out all the
economic activity gone schools not what
they need to be and you know all the
sort of pillars of those communities
are gone and these kids are growing up
in an environment with a lot of violence
and you know it is it to me I don't know
how kids come out of that environment
without PTSD because it's just so
stressful many of them many of them do
have PTSD I mean that there was like the
races the trauma studies like you can't
learn if you're getting traumatized you
know at home were in your neighborhood
and unfortunately that's the reality for
many many of our kids so we need to make
big investments to change that and you
know I mean I know reparations is a very
loaded term but we do have a debt that
we have to pay and and it should be and
there should be transformation of
neighborhoods and you know look there is
there is there is there ikanai there's
economic depression not just in the
african-american community that has to
be addressed and we should say that as
well the impacts of change that you've
talked about so eloquently have hit a
broad swath of communities it's just
that the african-american community
started off behind in so many ways
because of the institutional barriers
that we've created so there's a lot of
work to be done but here's the good news
I think the things that have that have
seemed sort of utopic and radical in the
past now seem like pragmatic answers to
a large number of Americans I think
there's more of a receptivity to
fundamental changes that aren't just
nibbling at the margins and I hope that
if Joe Biden becomes president that he
and his team take advantage of that and
and really advance a a visionary you
know set of policies that will that will
make change and that will appear to
people in their lives as important in
making change these democratic
institutions
you know these democratic institutions
rely on the confidence of people in them
to actually promote meaningful policy
and change and now more than ever that's
important by the way you know you're a
very successful businessperson this is
true of capitalism as well I think
there's a there's a crisis of capitalism
and a crisis of democracy and they're
intertwined and capitalists need to
become part of the solution here this
you know the idea of more and more
inequality of more wealth aggregation at
the top well large numbers of Americans
are struggling below
that's an unsustainable model and and we
need our leaders to make that clear and
we need business leaders to step forward
and say we understand and we're going to
we're gonna bring about fundamental
changes now the argument I've made is
that we we're just measuring our economy
all wrong that we should be measuring it
by human well-being health mental health
freedom from substance abuse childhood
success rates environmental
sustainability and things that would
actually speak to how we're doing as a
society because to your earlier point
the stock market and how families are
doing have essentially no relationship
anymore
I mean when these companies announced
layoffs their stock price goes up and
you can see clearly that many of these
companies can do more with fewer workers
people increasingly are seen as like a
dragon on your business yeah and that's
a big danger now you know one of the
things I remember so clearly from my
tenure in the White House during the
last economic crisis was you know
companies innovated and they figured out
how to do more with fewer people because
labor is a large part of their overhead
and so cause um you know yeah and you're
gonna see that this time as well and you
know that is a that is a big concern as
we as we come out of this so there is a
you know this is a this is a very
momentous time you know it started off
as a year about Trump or not Trump but
these cereal crises have have really
exposed not just him but the work that
we have to do as a country and people
are really focused on it and I think
that's positive but only if if our
leaders respond let's talk about mail
and stuff for all of our sakes you don't
want to go where lots of people are so
what if you need to go to the post
office don't worry just go to stamps
comm we use stamps calm on the campaign
because we had to mail a lot of stuff to
a lot of people with stamps calm you can
print postage on demand skip the line at
the post office just get er done from
home and they even give you discounts on
that action it's a freaking no-brainer
just stamps calm that thing stay away
from the post office stay healthy stay
good stay patriotic frankly we were very
very intelligent with our time in the
campaign so this was a massive time
saver for us so instead of lugging
packages to the post office and weighing
them and all stuffing do it right in the
office or right at home go to stamps
calm print it figure out everything you
need right where you are massively
simple massive time saver we're big fans
of stamps calm post office line 20th
century stamps calm 21st century right
now our listeners going to get a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
without having to make any long-term
commitments to go to stamps.com
and enter yang you click the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
why ang yang that's at stamps comm enter
yang yeah I spell my name
[Applause]
[Music]
we need a new New Deal a new American
social contract a new Marshall Plan for
the United States of America I don't
know which of those three you like the
best in terms of framing it probably but
you know all of them are so all of them
are set in a different time I'm not sure
that most Americans know what the
Marshall Plan it was anymore but but but
the principle is absolutely right how
about we could try America 2.0 does that
work for you it was that too wonky and
futuristic well that's certainly
contemporary that's it yeah that may be
a little too bloodless but it gets to
the point which is we've got to retool
here we need we need a new model within
the framework of our democracy and our
economic system we need a brand new
model that enhances the opportunity and
enhances opportunity for the broadest
number of people that David I'm
legitimately going to pick your
world-class political professional brain
for a minute because I've been trying to
figure out how to pitch this most
effectively so so it and so my instinct
and it's very consistent with me and who
I am is to say America 2.0 but I was
afraid that might seem alienating to
some people and so I was reaching
backwards and using things like new
American Contract new New Deal Marshall
Plan which you're probably right people
don't even know what the Marshall Plan
is anymore right so in your professional
opinion what should we call this effort
to reinvent America so that it's
actually working for most of us all of
us ideally but what more of us well
first let me offer this disclaimer
because in the past when I threw these
ideas out it generally followed a period
of reflection and testing so I kind of
knew how people reacted to these things
but you know the the idea relaunch
America you know
is is something that I would think about
you know this this idea of a hint an
inflection point that has a hopeful feel
to it you know to me 2.0 is a bit too
sterile and clinical relaunch America I
kind of like that relaunch America
yeah well David if you see that
billboards all over the country you'll
know where it came from that we came up
with it during this conversation what
well take a take it from an old
political hack my friend test it before
you use it because the great thing about
you know everybody thinks of research
polling and focus groups as manipulative
tools of a cynical political industry
but what I've learned over 40 years of
as a reporter and as a strategist is
that the wonderful thing about people is
they're there they are counterintuitive
they they you know they bring to it
things that you may not think about and
so I'm always eager to hear what people
have to say about I tested the heck out
of everything at the yang campaign we
were like data data data so that's how
we came up with freedom dividend we just
like tested every name because Social
Security for that was a good one
universal basic income yeah
well test relaunch America because I
think well it has to relaunch America
I think post Trump and given all these
crises I think they'll be there maybe a
receptivity to that so we'll see that's
my entry I couldn't agree more people
people want people want to know that we
recognize the severity of the crises the
hole that we're in the hole that many
families are in like we have to call an
end to business as usual because people
are dying people are suffering ways of
life are disintegrating I think all the
time again about all these small
business owners who are getting
decimated and the families in the Bronx
I talked to yesterday who were just
looking up saying like where the heck am
I going to get next month's rent like
it's it's everybody
and we have to go much much bigger when
I've talked to Joe he's seemed it to me
to recognize the need it's funny because
like no one thought of Joe Biden has
like the transformational figure he's
like I'm gonna change everything I mean
that's actually one of the reasons why
some people were like supportive of some
of his opponents like me perhaps yeah
you know I mean having run against Joe
and and you know seeing that like that
the the love that many people have for
him out on the trail I believe that he
is determined to step up like it like I
don't think he's going to go and say
like hey let's just like nibble at the
edges like I think you understand that
we do need like relaunch America we know
we'll have to present to him the data on
how best to name this thing so job
number one is have him be our president
then job number two is actually and I
actually want to say this and this could
these could be famous last words I'm
much more concerned about what happens
after Joe becomes president than I am
winning the election like I believe that
Joe is going to win and become our
president but then the real work begins
because we're still going to have like
tens of millions of Americans who are
completely at a loss as to what the way
forward looks like yeah I just I think
that's such an important point you know
because there is a you know there's a
passionate desire to get past this
Donald Trump era and I understand it but
if that's all that happens that's not
enough and my sense is that that's not
what Biden wants I you know I know Biden
well enough to believe that if he if he
wins he's gonna want to make his his
years as president count he's gonna he's
gonna want to be remembered for
something more than just being the guy
who beat Donald Trump and let me tell
you the opportunity that he has you know
one of the reasons why he's doing as
well as as he's doing in the polling I
wrote a piece about this the other
dan cnn.com is that he is culturally
inconvenient for Donald Trump he is just
not scary to the people who Donald Trump
hopes to scare about the Democratic
nominee and Trump kind of acknowledged
it last week in Tulsa last weekend when
he said when he talked about Biden being
the you know addled sort of captive of
the radical left but he said now he's
not radical left
he's never been radical left and I think
that was an admission that they just
can't make him scary so they're gonna
try and make his friends scary but the
opportunity that and you can see it in
the numbers Andrew he's doing far better
among white voters he's doing better
certainly better among college-educated
white voters who Trump carried last time
and he's paired the margin down among
non college educated white voters he's
even paired the margin down among white
evangelical voters but Biden I don't
think people are gonna look at Biden and
say he is a radical scary figure and
that gives him the opportunity to do
some very bold progressive things
because people have confidence that he
is not that he's not gonna throw the
system away he's not an extremist he's
not an ideologue he's a practical guy
yeah that that's actually very very
important where if Joe says hey we're
gonna do things big in this way then it
becomes the mainstream thing to do
whereas if someone else has suggested
you might look at it and say like oh
that that's very dramatic I think that's
the opportunity that he hasn't it's a
great opportunity for the country so you
know I'm and I also the other thing I
believe about Biden is if he becomes
president there is a wealth of talent
just when I may you're one of them
Andrew but there's a wealth of talent
out there just waiting to be unleashed
and after four years of mediocrity and
and worse and four years of subjugation
of
public institutions to the political
whims of the president and the dumbing
down of of government there's there
there's just all this energy waiting to
explode to rehabilitate the government
and innovate the government in a way
that can be really historic and Biden
has that opportunity and you know as you
know because you travel around there's
so many people who want to help so you
know he has to win the election as you
say that's job number one should not be
taken for granted and you know look he's
I think it is Biden's fundamental
qualities that as I said earlier really
have put him in a strong position here
decency empathy you know experience
solidity but you know he's been swept
along by forces no one could have
predicted that have really exposed Trump
in a big way all that said with all of
this unpredictability and you know you
know I'm just
and knowing that Trump will do anything
you know it is dangerous to be is
dangerous to look past the election and
no one should do that certainly we have
to fight fight fight to make sure that
Joe does win and then get to work you
actually have presented a very uplifting
portrait of what is possible I agree
with it 100% where I believe that we
have to do big things and that Joe is
going to be very very open to doing
things in a bigger way and that he in
some ways might be the ideal person to
bring the rest of America along that we
have to think bigger so this is the this
is the future we have to fight for I
don't know if it was your intention
David but I think
this might have been the most uplifting
framing of a Biden presidency that I
have seen maybe they could quote from
this podcast man they can like like
somehow make an ad out of it because
that I think that well listen man I know
I don't I don't recall
I don't recall Barack Obama ever being
up by 14 points so I don't know that
they're looking for that much advice
right now they seem to be doing pretty
well
and I give them and I give them all all
the credit for that but you know the one
thing the one cautionary note about
governance that I have to add is well
you know there's there's still a
Congress and Joe Biden will respect the
Congress as a as a co-equal branch of
government because he is a creature of
that Congress where he spent 36 years
but the Congress was you know there was
an intentional effort to block positive
change during the years of Obama and you
know Biden is going to face some of
those same forces there'll be
Republicans who'll say if he fails we
win zero-sum game he will have Democrats
you know this a diverse country and
democratic party unlike the Republican
Party is a very diverse party and there
may not be a complete agreement on
everything so it's gonna have to
overcome those hurdles and it will
matter you know who controls the
Congress because we you know there was a
vast difference in the first two years
of the Obama presidency when Democrats
controlled both houses of Congress in
the last six when they did not so you
know that those requests you remember it
well I mean you were there yeah you live
that different very sharply I know yeah
so yeah we you're right
we have to get some down ballot races
across the finish line as well we have
to give the new administration a chance
to succeed and it's one reason I gotta
say David I've done this you know much
less than you have but supporting down
ballot candidates is so fun and
inspirational because you like talk to
these folks who are running for
a state rep or Congress or sometimes
senator but generally something else and
there's such great people a lot of the
time you know they're like running for
office in their community in Austin
Texas or Massachusetts or wherever it is
I really enjoyed the heck out of it I
couldn't agree with you more I am so
inspired by people I meet around the
country who stepped forward you know I
have a young student who's running for
from the Institute of Politics at the
University of Chicago named Zack steppe
who's running for the legislature in in
Ohio he's in you know he's I I think he
must be 24 years old or or something but
as smart and capable and well motivated
a young man as you'd ever want to meet
and just just inspiring as I'll get out
and there are people all over this
country like that that's you know
working with young people gives me hope
because they they are undaunted by the
challenges and unbounded by conventional
thinking and they are all about trying
to make the future better and and I
think they have the power to do it
so yeah I'm you know I wrote a book
called believer Andrew so I'm kind of my
brand is established I I tend to the
optimistic side but even in these dark
days I do see a better future and I'm
and I'm pulling hard for it I love it
let's put some more young people in
charge I agree I think if your Institute
of Politics alums and students were in
charge we'd already be in much better
shape because having met them they were
so idealistic and energized you you do
the next generation of great service
David because like they you know they
they get from you a sense of both like
practicality but possibility you know
like you've actually been there you've
been to the mountaintop and I'm a
hundred percent sure that some of your
students are going to wind up doing
something incredible that makes us all
proud and makes a huge difference well
in right back at you
I mean your candidacy inspired a lot of
these young people to believe that there
was another path and you know so you
you've you've played a great role and I
know you'll continue to play a great
role in in blazing that trail anyway
listen brother it's great to be with you
I look forward to a time when we're not
staring at each other through little
boxes on a zoom screen but we can sit
across a table again
yeah I'm looking forward to that too all
the best to you and the family and yeah
we're going to do our best man we're
gonna get the next generation fired up
and put them in position to lead us in
the right direction amen
great to be with you
[Music]